fraîchement nommé au ministère de la
santé olivier ferrand l'a annoncé hier
matin au micro de france info il n'y
aura pas de période de chauffe
je connais les dossiers et olivier
ferrand a raison c'est lui qui a entamé
les discussions lundi à l'assemblée
nationale concernant les quarante et un
mille amendements déposés une prise de
parole qui n'a pas toujours été facile
et olivier vers ans a dû donner de la
voix pour se faire entendre auprès de
ses collègues
le système actuel à bien des qualités
nous ne manquons jamais de le rappeler
est la première d'entre elles est celle
d'un système qui fonctionne par
répartition mais il a aussi des défauts
et ce sont ses défauts que nous devons
corriger le premier c'est d'être d'une
telle complexité qu'il en devient
incompréhensible et qui ne suscite pas à
la confiance notamment pour les plus
jeunes
je pars mire du système actuel mesdames
et messieurs les députés du haut de mes
trente neuf ans j'ai déjà cotisé à
quatre régimes de retraite différent
s'il vous plaît mais chacun sait aussi
que le système actuel est injuste pour
beaucoup de concitoyens
je pense aux femmes et à tous ceux
nombreux pour qui la vie professionnelle
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille
si le nouveau ministre de la santé
évoque une ambition immense concernant
les débats sur la réforme des retraites
le texte est toujours dénoncé par
l'opposition
au même moment une nouvelle
manifestation parisienne s'est déroulé
de la place de l'opéra jusqu'aux abords
du palais bourbon une manifestation
cette fois-ci autorisée qui a permis à
quelques gilet jaune de s'approcher de
l'assemblée nationale sur place des
stands ont été installés ou des députés
de l'opposition ont pris la parole pour
exprimer leur désapprobation
on est conscient que c'est pas l'intérêt
du parlement que les choses vont se
passer mais à l'extérieur mais c'est
pour ça qu'on est venu simplement
d'abord se rappeler au bon souvenir de
l'assemblée nationale de leur député
pour dire qu on les oubliera pas
n'oubliera pas qu'ils comptent voter
quoi que ce soit par une manifestation
nationale la généralisation de la grève
on a besoin de replanter dans le décor
le fait qu'on n'est pas des rigolos et
qu' on n'a pas fait tout ce qu'on a fait
depuis le 5 décembre simplement pour
gagner la bataille des idées
c'est ça qui est le plus insupportable
ils sont en train de démanteler un des
piliers du patrimoine social français et
ils font mine de quelque part vouloir en
réalité du progrès alors qu'ils ne font
que reculer l'âge de la retraite par la
presse
attaquer les pensions sans aucune
légitimité donc je peux vous dire je
pense que dans l'assemblée ça va ça va
être assez chaud pendant plusieurs
semaines alors que le vote est prévu
dans l'hémicycle le 3 mars prochain des
discussions houleuses devrait rythmer
les débats pendant plusieurs semaines et
pour tenir ce calendrier les députés
devront étudier les quarante et un mille
amendements en 19 jours soit plus de
2000 quotidiennement